One thing that's been interesting watching the rise of the New York mayoral candidate, Zohran Mamdani, who's a Democrat, is watching precisely how much of the Democratic machine has come out to support him. After he won the Democratic primary, of course, normally, the party would fall in behind him. And in fact, some prominent Democrats have come forward and endorsed him. But not all of them, not some of the most important New York Democrats-- Senate Minority Leader Chuck Schumer, House Minority Leader Hakeem Jeffries, former New York Mayor Michael Bloomberg.
观察纽约市长候选人佐兰·曼达尼（Zohran Mamdani，民主党人）的崛起，一件有趣的事情是观察到民主党机器在多大程度上出来支持他。当然，在他赢得民主党初选后，按理说该党会支持他。事实上，一些著名的民主党人已经站出来支持他了。但并非所有人都支持，一些重要的纽约民主党人并没有——比如参议院少数党领袖查克·舒默（Chuck Schumer）、众议院少数党领袖哈基姆·杰弗里斯（Hakeem Jeffries）和前纽约市长迈克尔·布隆伯格（Michael Bloomberg）。
And I'm bringing all this up today because, watching this, it reminded me of the story of another charismatic politician ages ago, Harold Washington, the first Black mayor of Chicago. Harold became mayor back in 1983. And that was so revolutionary at the time, that a Black man would become mayor of the city of Chicago, that after the primary, the Democratic Party turned on him. And an old-school Democrat, a white guy, ran as an independent against Harold in the general election, much like Andrew Cuomo has done with Mamdani.
我今天提到这一切，是因为看到这一幕，让我想起了很久以前另一位充满魅力的政治家——哈罗德·华盛顿（Harold Washington），芝加哥第一位黑人市长。哈罗德在1983年当选市长。在当时，黑人能成为芝加哥市长是一件具有革命性意义的事情，以至于初选结束后，民主党转而反对他。一位老派的民主党人，一个白人，在大选中作为独立候选人与哈罗德竞争，这就像安德鲁·库莫（Andrew Cuomo）对曼达尼所做的那样。
And back then, most of the Democratic machine endorsed the white guy in the general election. Then, once Harold took office, Democrats continued to fight him and the changes that he wanted to make. I want to be clear, I don't want to oversimplify in comparing these two stories. So much of Harold's story is very different than Zohran Mamdani's. The opposition to Harold was over race. The opposition to Mamdani is more about his views on Israel and his socialism or progressivism, or whatever you want to call it. The race and religion, the fact that he's Muslim, is definitely in there, too.
当时，大多数民主党机器在大选中支持那个白人。随后，哈罗德上任后，民主党人继续对抗他和想要做出的改变。我想明确一点，我不想在比较这两个故事时过于简化。哈罗德的故事与佐兰·曼达尼的故事有很大不同。针对哈罗德的反对主要基于种族。针对曼达尼的反对更多是关于他对以色列的看法以及他的社会主义或进步主义主张，或者随你怎么称呼。种族和宗教，他是一名穆斯林这一事实，无疑也包含在其中。
But Harold's story is a parable about a Democrat whose very existence made the party have to question what it was all about, which seemed very much like Mamdani. So we're going to replay his story today. Back in 1997, 10 years after Harold died, we did a full episode about him.
但哈罗德的故事是一个寓言，讲述了一位民主党人，他的存在迫使该党不得不质疑其自身的意义，这看起来非常像曼达尼的情况。所以今天我们要重播他的故事。早在1997年，即哈罗德去世10年后，我们就做了一期关于他的完整节目。
And can I say, if you don't know anything about Harold Washington, you're in for a treat. He is this charismatic, idealistic man, very funny, very smart, great talker, a Democrat framing issues with a skill that it is really hard to think of any Democrat in office right now who does it as well. But also a pragmatist, somebody who got elected, somebody who got things done. So I hope you like this. It's one of my favorite episodes we've ever done. Here we go. Here's that show from 1997.
而且我可以这么说，如果你对哈罗德·华盛顿一无所知，那你将大饱眼福。他是一位充满魅力、理想主义的人，非常风趣、非常聪明、口才极佳。作为一名民主党人，他阐述议题的技巧很难让人联想到现在任职的任何一位民主党人能做得这么好。但他也是一个实用主义者，一个能够当选、能够把事情办成的人。所以我希望你们喜欢这期节目。这是我们做过最喜欢的节目之一。我们要开始了。这是1997年的那档节目。
Before our story begins, let's remember how it used to be. Jacky lived on the South Side, in a Black neighborhood. The city didn't enforce the housing code properly, didn't investigate arsons.
在我们故事开始之前，让我们回想一下过去的样子。杰基（Jacky）住在南区一个黑人社区。市政府没有妥善执行住房法规，也没有调查纵火案。
There would be fires going on in Woodlawn daily, several times a day. And it was just fire engines all the time. And so my daughter started to believe that when buildings got old and died, like people got old and died, that you knew a building was old and was dying because it would burn up.
伍德朗（Woodlawn）每天都会发生火灾，一天好几次。到处都是消防车。所以我的女儿开始相信，当建筑变老死亡时，就像人变老死亡一样，你知道一栋建筑老了快要死了，是因为它会烧起来。
Before our story begins, Chicago was run by the Democratic machine, and Black aldermen, like Danny Davis, would turn out to vote for the machine, election after election. But the machine didn't reward the Black wards for those votes the way it paid back the white wards on the North Side, with street cleanings and sewers, with newly paved roads and sidewalks, economic development money.
在我们故事开始之前，芝加哥由民主党机器统治，像丹尼·戴维斯（Danny Davis）这样的黑人议员，选举一次又一次地动员投票支持该机器。但是，该机器并没有像回馈北区的白人选区那样回馈黑人选区，没有为这些选票提供街道清理、下水道、新铺设的道路和人行道，以及经济发展资金。
Well, actually, we had called the areas colonies. I mean, and just basically picking up the garbage in these wards, just trying to keep them clean was a real problem. The person who was elected, there would be so much focus on garbage pickup that you'd almost have to just be the garbage alderman. I mean, I recall telling people time and time again that I was tired of just being the garbage alderman.
嗯，其实，我们称这些区域为殖民地。我的意思是，基本上只是清理这些选区的垃圾，仅仅试图保持清洁就是一个真正的问题。选出的人，所有的注意力都会集中在垃圾收集上，以至于你几乎不得不成为一名“垃圾议员”。我的意思是，我记得一遍又一遍地告诉人们，我厌倦了仅仅成为一名“垃圾议员”。
Before our story begins, the Chicago political machine squeezed Black kids into mobile trailers behind public schools, rather than let them attend white schools just blocks away. Before our story begins, the Chicago machine built high-rise public housing to hold Blacks on the South Side and keep them from moving into white neighborhoods.
在我们故事开始之前，芝加哥政治机器将黑人孩子挤在公立学校后面的移动拖车里，而不是让他们进入仅仅几个街区外的白人学校。在我们故事开始之前，芝加哥机器建造了高层公共住房，将黑人安置在南区，并防止他们搬进白人社区。
Before our story begins, the Chicago political machine built a system of highways that coincidentally divided Black neighborhoods from white and particularly insulated the mayor's all-white neighborhood, Bridgeport. Typical inequities-- unemployment in the white 11th Ward was 0%; unemployment in the 4th Ward, where Blacks lived, was 25%.
在我们故事开始之前，芝加哥政治机器修建了一个高速公路系统，巧合地将黑人社区与白人社区隔离开来，特别是孤立了市长全白的社区布里奇波特（Bridgeport）。典型的不平等——第11区（白人区）的失业率为0%；而黑人居住的第4区的失业率为25%。
This is a story about one ethnic group doing what so many other ethnic groups have done in this country-- put its own candidate in City Hall, won the mayor's office. But because this ethnic group happened to be Black, what happened was unlike anything that happens when an Italian politician or an Irish politician or a Jewish politician takes City Hall. White voters deserted their own political party. White politicians tried to stage a public, slow-motion coup. And the mayor faced pressures that were different from those faced by any white mayor of any city in America. And nobody tried to pretend that the fight was not about race.
这是一个关于一个族群在我国做了许多其他族群所做过的事情的故事——将自己的候选人送进市政厅，赢得了市长职位。但因为这个族群恰好是黑人，所发生的一切与意大利裔政治家、爱尔兰裔政治家或犹太裔政治家接管市政厅时发生的事情截然不同。白人选民抛弃了他们自己的政党。白人政治家试图策划一场公开的、慢动作的政变。而这位市长所面临的压力，与美国任何城市的任何白人市长所面临的压力都不同。没有人试图假装这场斗争与种族无关。
Good evening. You're on with Harold Washington.
晚上好。你现在连线的是哈罗德·华盛顿。
Good evening. Mr. Washington, could you clear up a point for me? I understand that once you move into City Hall, you're going to remove all the elevator boxes and replace them with vines. Is that-- is that true?
晚上好。华盛顿先生，你能帮我澄清一个问题吗？我听说一旦你搬进市政厅，你就要移除所有的电梯箱，换上藤蔓。这是……这是真的吗？
What? Replace them with what?
什么？换上什么？
With vines.
藤蔓。
Vines? V-I-N-E-S?
藤蔓？藤-蔓（V-I-N-E-S）？
You know what? I'm not even--
你知道吗？我甚至不——
No, no.
不，不。
I'm not even going to ask you why.
我甚至不去问你为什么。
No, I don't think we have 3 million Tarzans in this city. [LAUGHS]
不，我不认为我们这个城市有300万个泰山。[笑声]
Good evening. Randall is gone.
晚上好。兰德尔（Randall）不在了。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today we bring you the story of Harold Washington, Chicago's first Black mayor. He died early in his second term of office, back in 1987. Act One of our program today is about what happened during Harold's life. Then we have a short Act Two about what came afterwards.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，节目是《这就是美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天，我们为你带来芝加哥第一位黑人市长哈罗德·华盛顿的故事。他在1987年的第二个任期初去世了。我们今天节目的第一幕是关于哈罗德生前发生的事情。然后我们将有一段简短的第二幕，讲述之后发生的事情。
A word about the voices you're going to be hearing over the course of this hour, it's mostly people who were close to Harold Washington, many of them activists and politicians-- Lu Palmer, Judge Eugene Pincham, Congressman Danny Davis, then-alderman Eugene Sawyer. There are people from his administration-- Jacky Grimshaw, Grayson Mitchell, Timuel Black, and some reporters who followed his story-- Vernon Jarrett, Monroe Anderson, Gary Rivlin, Laura Washington, who later became his press secretary. There will also be an occasional opponent or voter. Stay with us.
关于你在这一小时节目中将听到的声音，多是与哈罗德·华盛顿关系密切的人，其中许多是活动家和政治家——卢·帕尔默（Lu Palmer）、尤金·平查姆法官（Judge Eugene Pincham）、国会议员丹尼·戴维斯（Danny Davis）、时任议员尤金·索耶（Eugene Sawyer）。还有他政府里的人——杰基·格里姆肖（Jacky Grimshaw）、格雷森·米切尔（Grayson Mitchell）、蒂缪尔·布莱克（Timuel Black），以及一些跟踪报道他的记者——弗农·贾雷特（Vernon Jarrett）、门罗·安德森（Monroe Anderson）、加里·里夫林（Gary Rivlin）、劳拉·华盛顿（Laura Washington），后来成为了他的新闻秘书。偶尔也会有反对者或选民。请留下来。
This American Life. Act One, Yesterday. For decades, Chicago politics had been run with an iron hand by the legendary political boss, Richard J. Daley. Our story begins just after his death, in 1976, when the machine was sputtering a bit with no strong leader and the possibility, a small possibility, of change. To give you a sense of what it meant to be a loyal black alderman in the Chicago machine at that time, consider what happened in City Hall the day Richard Daley died.
《这就是美国生活》。第一幕，昨天。几十年来，芝加哥政坛一直由传奇的政治老板理查德·J·戴利（Richard J. Daley）铁腕统治。我们的故事开始于他1976年去世后，当时该机器因为没有强有力的领导人而有点陷入困境，并出现了变革的一丝可能性。为了让你了解当时作为芝加哥机器中忠诚黑人议员的意义，看看理查德·戴利去世那天在市政厅发生了什么。
By tradition, the president pro tem of the city council should have at least occupied the mayor's office until such time as a process was determined for the election of a new mayor.
按照传统，市议会临时议长至少应该占用市长办公室，直到确定选举新市长的程序为止。
And who was the--
而谁是——
That was Wilson Frost, a loyal Black alderman from the 34th Ward, a Daley Democrat, a lawyer, impeccable reputation, impeccable credentials. The only misqualification he had was he's Black. God ordained that he be born Black. And the power structure sent police officers to the fifth floor, armed to sit at the door to prevent Frost from even entering the mayor's office. That was a tremendous insult.
那是威尔逊·弗罗斯特（Wilson Frost），一位来自第34区的忠诚黑人议员，一位戴利民主党人，律师，声誉无可挑剔，资历无可挑剔。他唯一的“不合格”之处就是他是黑人。上帝规定他生为黑人。权力结构派武装警察到五楼坐在门口，阻止弗罗斯特进入市长办公室。那是一种巨大的侮辱。
It was an insult, but it was not unusual. The white machine picked who the Black leaders would be. And mostly, those leaders did what they were told. Blacks in Chicago had nowhere to go but the Democratic machine. They were stuck.
这是一种侮辱，但并不罕见。白人机器挑选谁将成为黑人领导人。而且大多时候，这些领导人按要求行事。芝加哥的黑人除了民主党机器外无处可去。他们被困住了。
But then there were a series of famous and especially infuriating insults from the white political establishment. Biggest among them, Black voters finally elected an anti-machine candidate named Jane Byrne, who, once in office, betrayed them, sucked up to the white machine, made appointments and decisions specifically to prove she was not in the pocket of Black Chicago.
但随后发生了一系列来自白人政治建制派的著名且极其令人愤怒的侮辱。其中最大的一点是，黑人选民最终选出了一位名为简·伯恩（Jane Byrne）的反机器候选人，她一上任就背叛了他们，向白人机器献媚，做出的任命和决定专门为了证明她不是黑芝加哥的囊中之物。
Then, circumstances came together-- some by planning, some by luck-- that made it possible to elect a Black mayor. The planning-- organizers registered over 100,000 minority voters, held rallies and meetings, declaring it was time to elect a Black mayor. The luck-- two white candidates split the white vote. One more piece of luck-- the Chicago Democratic Party had created, in spite of itself, Harold Washington. Vernon Jarrett was an old friend and a vocal newspaper columnist.
然后，各种情况汇合在一起——有些是计划好的，有些是靠运气——使得选举一位黑人市长成为可能。计划方面——组织者登记了超过10万名少数族裔选民，举行集会和会议，宣称是时候选出一位黑人市长了。运气方面——两名白人候选人瓜分了白人选票。又多了一点运气——芝加哥民主党，尽管它自己不愿，还是创造了哈罗德·华盛顿。弗农·贾雷特是一位老朋友，也是一位直言不讳的报纸专栏作家。
And Harold was in that party now. Don't forget, Harold had been a precinct captain. His father had groomed him as a precinct captain since he was, what, 11 years old. But his father was done wrong. So Harold is an unusual person in that he nursed this resentment of how the Democratic Party had deserted his father at one time, when his father ran for alderman of the 3rd Ward.
哈罗德那时就在那个党里。别忘了，哈罗德曾是一名选区队长。他父亲从他11岁起就培养他当选区队长。但他父亲遭到了不公待遇。所以哈罗德是一个不寻常的人，因为他一直怀有对民主党曾经如何抛弃他父亲的怨恨，当时他父亲竞选第3区的议员。
He was a confused guy, got a little sense of mission in him, and wanting to do the right thing, but yet, he was balanced off by this pragmatism that you got to play ball, to a degree, with the organization. And he was correct. He wouldn't have made it without the Democratic machine.
他是一个困惑的人，心中有一点使命感，想要做正确的事，但同时，他又被一种实用主义所平衡，即你必须在一定程度上与该组织达成妥协。他是对的。没有民主党机器，他不会成功。
Usually, in Chicago, political activists had a choice. They could go with politicians who were good on the issues, but then had no political experience dealing with the machine. Or they could get hacks who knew the machine, but were terrible on the issues. Washington was the rarest kind of politician-- delivered on the issues, knew the machine-- which was why, in fact, he did not want the job. Lu Palmer was at the center of the effort to draft a Black mayor.
通常，在芝加哥，政治活动家有两种选择。他们可以选择那些议题表现好，但缺乏处理机器政治经验的政治家。或者他们可以选择那些精通机器政治，但在议题上表现极差的官僚。华盛顿是那种极其罕见的政治家——议题上能有作为，又了解机器——这事实上正是他不想接受这份工作的原因。卢·帕尔默处于起草黑人市长人选工作的中心。
Well, we talked to Harold. He was reluctant, very reluctant. At the time, he was in Congress and was enjoying being a congressman.
嗯，我们和哈罗德谈过。他很勉强，非常勉强。当时他在国会，很享受当国会议员的日子。
Enjoying it partly because he was far from the machine.
享受它部分是因为他远离了机器政治。
He set some requirements, how much money we'd have to raise. We'd have to get 50,000 new voters.
他提出了一些要求，我们需要筹集多少钱。我们需要争取5万名新选民。
He asked that thinking, well, you'll never get that or--
他提出那个要求是因为心想，反正你们永远也做不到，或者——
He used 50,000, knowing that no way in the world are they going to come up with 50,000 new re-- and that was hard in those days to come up with 50,000 registered voters.
他用了5万这个数字，深知无论如何他们也不可能筹集到5万名新登记选民——在那个年代，要筹集5万名登记选民是很困难的。
They registered 130,000 new voters.
他们登记了13万名新选民。
May I jump ahead a moment? Do you know what put Harold Washington over with the broad masses of Black people was when they had the primary debates.
我能先跳过一段吗？你知道是什么让哈罗德·华盛顿赢得了黑人大众的支持吗？是当他们进行初选辩论的时候。
Oh! The triumph was a televised debate.
哦！那场胜利是一场电视辩论。
Because you had Daley. You had Byrne. And then you had somebody who could talk-- Harold.
因为你有戴利。你有伯恩。然后你还有一个人能说会道——哈罗德。
Let's review that lineup. Daley was Richard M. Daley, son of the late mayor, Richard J. Daley. Byrne was Jane Byrne, the then-incumbent mayor. And Harold-- you already know Harold. Those were the three Democratic contenders in the mayoral race. It is the fall of 1983.
让我们回顾一下那个人选阵容。戴利是理查德·M·戴利，已故市长理查德·J·戴利的儿子。伯恩是简·伯恩，时任现任市长。哈罗德——你已经了解哈罗德了。那是市长竞选中三名民主党候选人。那是1983年的秋天。
Here's a typical exchange between them. The three of them were asked at one point what they would do, if anything, about the police department's Office of Professional Standards, the place in the police department which handles complaints about police misconduct and brutality. Jane Byrne and Richard Daley sound basically like normal politicians. They offer dull truisms, like--
这是他们之间典型的交流。他们三人在某个时刻被问到，关于警察局的专业标准办公室（该机构处理警察不当行为和暴力的投诉），他们会做什么（如果有的话）。简·伯恩和理查德·戴利听起来基本上像普通的政治家。他们说出平淡的陈词滥调，比如——
I believe that the members of the police board, chaired by Reverend Wilbur Daniels, really do take that job very seriously.
我相信由威尔伯·丹尼尔斯（Reverend Wilbur Daniels）牧师担任主席的警察委员会成员，确实非常认真地对待那项工作。
Here is the most specific that Richard Daley, then state's attorney, got that day.
这是当时担任州检察长的理查德·戴利那天所能说的最具体的内容。
I think like anything else, there must be improvement. And there is nothing wrong with improvement in the Office of Professional Standards.
我认为像其他任何事情一样，必须有改进。专业标准办公室需要改进，这没什么错。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
When Harold Washington comes on, what is most noticeable is that he sounds like a human being.
当哈罗德·华盛顿上台时，最引人注目的是他听起来像一个真正的人。
The precise question is, what would I do to improve the Office of Professional Standards? When I answer it, I'll be the only one who answered the question.
明确的问题是，我将采取什么措施改善专业标准办公室？当我回答它时，我将是唯一一个回答了问题的人。
[APPLAUSE, CHEERING]
[掌声，欢呼声]
The Office of Professional Standards was arrived at after a long and torturous situation in this city in which members, not all, but members of the Chicago Police Department, consistently refused to be adequate and professional in their handling of Hispanic, Black people. It's just that simple.
专业标准办公室是在这个城市经历了一个漫长而痛苦的情况后建立的，当时芝加哥警察局的成员，虽然不是全部，但部分成员一贯拒绝在处理西班牙裔和黑人时做到足够专业。就是这么简单。
What happened was he became plausible to the Black community. Suddenly they heard somebody who was articulate, knew what he was talking about, and was forceful.
发生了什么呢，他在黑人社区变得可信了。突然间，他们听到一个人口齿伶俐，知道自己在说什么，而且充满力量。
In the first place, the appointees, all but nine, are political appointees. Many of the investigators are wedded to or related to police members of the Chicago Police Department.
首先，这些任命者中除了九个之外，全都是政治任命。许多调查员与芝加哥警察局的警察成员联姻或有亲戚关系。
A lot of people, Black people, had felt all along that we'd been bossed by the dunderheads. They are not that bright. They don't know that much. And Harold, Harold Washington standing there between Jane Byrne and Richard M. Daley, the son, so cool, so well-read, that Black people were just thrilled. It was like watching Michael Jordan with a basketball.
许多黑人一直觉得我们被笨蛋统治着。他们没那么聪明。他们了解得不多。而哈罗德，哈罗德·华盛顿站在简·伯恩和理查德·M·戴利（那个儿子）之间，那么冷静，那么博学，黑人们简直激动坏了。就像看迈克尔·乔丹打篮球一样。
Mr. Brzeczek, unfortunately, at the behest of this mayor, as a minion of this mayor, as a subaltern of this mayor, as a subordinate of this mayor, has destroyed his credibility--
布热切克先生（Mr. Brzeczek），不幸的是，在这一任市长的指使下，作为这一任市长的爪牙，作为这一任市长的下属，作为这一任市长的部下，毁掉了他的信誉——
Harold used to use words that even some of these journalists, these white journalists had to scratch their head and go to the dictionary. Black people love that.
哈罗德过去经常使用一些词汇，连这些记者，这些白人记者都得挠头去翻字典。黑人喜欢那样。
And he jumped on Jane Byrne and took her by surprise, shocked her. And she was still reeling from the shock. And I shall never forget it that night. I said, this man's got it made. He's in.
他突然向简·伯恩发起攻击，让她措手不及，震惊了她。而她还在震惊中无法回神。我永远不会忘记那一晚。我说，这个人成功了。他稳赢了。
Here's one way that being a Black candidate for office is different from being a white candidate. If you're Black, you get thrown into the chasm of misunderstanding that divides white America from Black America, in a way that white politicians almost never are. Two Americas simply see certain things differently.
这是一种作为黑人公职候选人与白人候选人不同的地方。如果你是黑人，你会被扔进分裂白人美国和黑人美国的误解鸿沟里，这在白人政治家身上几乎从未发生过。两个美国人仅仅是以不同的方式看待某些事情。
For instance, what should Harold Washington say about the late mayor, Richard J. Daley? Many white Chicagoans still held him in awe, while Black and Latino Chicago, for good reasons, had a different take. Daley openly stood against integration of the city's neighborhoods. The night after Martin Luther King, Jr.'s death, he ordered police to shoot to kill rioters. Well, here's what Harold decided to say.
例如，哈罗德·华盛顿应该对已故市长理查德·J·戴利说些什么？许多白人芝加哥人仍然对他怀有敬畏之心，而黑人和拉丁裔芝加哥人，出于充分的理由，有不同的看法。戴利公开反对城市社区的种族融合。马丁·路德·金去世后的那天晚上，他下令警察枪杀暴徒。嗯，这是哈罗德决定要说的话。
When he says that he would hope that I would have all the good qualities of past mayors, there are no good qualities of past mayors to be had. None. None. None.
当他说希望我拥有过去市长所有的优良品质时，过去市长根本没有优良品质可言。没有。没有。没有。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
None. I did not mourn at the bier of the late mayor. I regret anyone dying. I have no regrets about him leaving. He was a racist from the core, head to toe and hip to hip. There's no doubt about it. And he spewed and fought and oppressed Black people to the point that some of them thought that was the way they were supposed to live, just like some slaves on the plantation thought that was the way they were supposed to live.
没有。我没有在已故市长的灵柩前哀悼。我为任何人的去世感到遗憾。我不后悔他的离开。他是个彻头彻尾、从头到脚、里里外外彻彻底底的种族主义者。毫无疑问。他喷毒液、争斗并压迫黑人，以至于他们中有些人认为那就是他们理应生活的方式，就像种植园里的一些奴隶认为那就是他们理应生活的方式一样。
It was just like everything else he did and said; it was historic. And no one would challenge the late mayor on anything, much less call him that kind of name. And I think that was what made him so provocative. It's what made him so loved by the people who supported him and so hated by the people who wanted to deny him the office. He didn't mince any words.
这就像他所做和所说的其他一切一样；这是历史性的。没有人会挑战已故市长任何事情，更不用说给他贴上那种标签了。我认为这正是让他如此具有煽动性的原因。这也正是他被支持他的人如此爱戴，又被那些想剥夺他职位的人如此痛恨的原因。他说话从不含糊。
I'd give no hosannas to a racist, nor do I appreciate or respect his son. If his name were anything other than Daley, his campaign would be a joke. He has nothing to offer anybody but a bent-up tin-can smile, no background.
我不会向种族主义者献上任何赞歌，我也不会欣赏或尊重他的儿子。如果他的名字不是戴利，他的竞选就是个笑话。除了弯曲的廉价笑容，他没有任何东西可以提供给任何人，毫无背景。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
And he runs on the legacy of his name, an insult to common sense and decency. Everything I've ever got in the world, I worked for it. Nobody gave me anything.
而他靠他名字的遗产竞选，这是对常识和尊严的侮辱。我一生中得到的一切，都是我通过工作获得的。没有人给我任何东西。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
The primary taught him that he could transcend being the third candidate, of being the Black candidate. And he could take that Adam Powell positioning. He could take that Marcus Garvey positioning, where you're the hybrid between the politician and the public man. And you become somewhere between Muhammad Ali, Michael Jackson, somewhere in superstar.
初选告诉他，他可以超越第三候选人、黑人候选人的身份。他可以采纳亚当·鲍威尔（Adam Powell）的那种定位。他可以采纳马库斯·加维（Marcus Garvey）的那种定位，即你是政治家和公众人物之间的混合体。而你变得介于穆罕默德·阿里（Muhammad Ali）、迈克尔·杰克逊（Michael Jackson）之间的某种超级巨星。
No, though I may sound abrasive, I have no malice toward anybody. I have a job to do. I've got places to go and things to do. And I approach this job just like any masterful surgeon, when you have to cut out a cancer. I cut it out with no emotion. Get it out. Get out.
不，虽然我听起来可能生硬，但我对任何人没有恶意。我有一份工作要做。我有地方要去，有事情要做。我像任何精湛的外科医生一样处理这份工作，当必须切除癌症时。我毫无感情地切除它。把它切掉。滚出去。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
This dominant culture may have messed up my pocket, but they haven't messed up my head one bit. [CHUCKLES] I believe in the powers of redemption. And I simply cannot believe, in the God I worship, that he would permit us to sit on this Earth for 400 years-- or rather, in this country for 400 years-- and suffer the indignities which we have suffered, piled time after time, high after high, and so heavy, it has almost broken the backs of one of the most powerful people in this world.
这种统治文化可能搞乱了我的口袋，但他们一点也没搞乱我的头脑。[轻笑] 我相信救赎的力量。我简直无法相信，在我所信仰的上帝眼中，他会允许我们坐在这个地球上400年——或者更确切地说，在这个国家400年——并遭受我们所遭受的耻辱，一次又一次地堆积，高处叠高处，如此沉重，几乎压垮了世界上最强大的民族之一。
I can't believe there is no redemption. But that redemption is not going to come out in hatred. It's going to come out in positive attitudes toward our fellow man. We've come into the 1980s with an understanding that we have not just a right, but a responsibility to give the best that we have to a society. We want to give it. And we're going to give it if we have to beat them across the head and knock them down and make them take it. We're going to give it to them.
我不相信没有救赎。但这种救赎不会源于仇恨。它将源于对我们同胞的积极态度。我们带着一种理解进入了1980年代，即我们不仅有权利，而且有责任为社会贡献我们最好的东西。我们想贡献它。如果我们不得不敲打他们的头，把他们打倒，强迫他们接受，我们也会贡献它。我们要把它献给他们。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
During this election and during Harold Washington's terms as mayor, in Chicago, every day was the day after the OJ verdict. Every day was a day when Black and white Chicago took a look at the same set of facts and drew two different conclusions. For instance, when the media raised questions about Washington's past, it made white Chicagoans question his qualifications for office, but it made minority voters more loyal.
在这次选举期间和哈罗德·华盛顿担任市长期间，在芝加哥，每一天都是辛普森（OJ Simpson）裁决之后的日子。每一天都是黑人和白人芝加哥人审视同一组事实却得出两种不同结论的日子。例如，当媒体对华盛顿的过去提出疑问时，这让白人芝加哥人质疑他的任职资格，但却让少数族裔选民更加忠诚。
In 1983, when Harold announced his candidacy, 95% of Black people never heard of him. And what happened was the white power-structured media first criticized Harold for having been convicted of a tax violation. He failed to file his returns.
1983年，当哈罗德宣布参选时，95%的黑人从未听说过他。结果是，白人权力结构的媒体首先批评哈罗德曾因违反税法被定罪。他没有提交报税单。
We should be precise about this. It wasn't that he hadn't paid. It's that he hadn't filed the return.
我们应该对此精确一点。并不是他没交税。而是他没有提交报税单。
He hadn't filed the return. That's right. He'd paid withholding.
他没有提交报税单。没错。他预扣税款已经交了。
Right.
对。
There was nothing to it. So what difference does it make? But the point is, when this occurred, it gave him publicity that he otherwise would not have gotten. Many people in the Black community resented the criticisms being leveled against him.
那根本没什么。所以这有什么区别呢？但重点是，当这种情况发生时，它给了他本不会得到的曝光率。黑人社区的许多人对他所受的批评感到愤慨。
They then said, well, you're not married. You can't be mayor if you're not married. We made Jane Byrne marry McMullen. We made Jim Thompson marry Jane Thompson. We made Kennedy, in the Senate, go back to his wife. You cannot be a viable politician if you're not married.
他们然后说，嗯，你没结婚。如果你没结婚，你就不能当市长。我们让简·伯恩嫁给了麦克马伦（McMullen）。我们让吉姆·汤普森（Jim Thompson）娶了简·汤普森（Jane Thompson）。我们让参议院的肯尼迪（Kennedy）回到他妻子身边。如果你没结婚，你就不能成为一个合格的政治家。
Here again, he did something that Blacks weren't accustomed to seeing Blacks do. He stood up. And he said, I'm not going to get married. Everybody thought, man, go marry, if this is going to make-- and he said, I'm not. Nobody can tell me to marry. I don't want to marry. My marital status has nothing to do with my qualifications as mayor.
在这里他又做了一件黑人们不习惯看到黑人做的事。他站了出来。他说，我不会结婚。每个人都想，天哪，结婚吧，如果这能使——他说，我不会。没人能告诉我要结婚。我不想结婚。我的婚姻状况与我作为市长的资格无关。
And here again, the Black community looked at him with a great deal more respect now, because many of the people, Black folks who married, don't want to be married no way. So they said, go on, Harold.
在这里，黑人社区现在以更多的尊重看待他，因为许多人，那些结婚的黑人，其实根本就不想结婚。所以他们说，去吧，哈罗德。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But he got some more publicity. And quite frankly, you would have to concede-- I certainly will say it-- that had a white candidate with the same baggage been running, there's no way in the world he would been elected mayor.
但他得到了更多的曝光率。说实话，你不得不承认——我当然要说——如果是一个背负同样包袱的白人候选人在竞选，他绝对不可能当选市长。
How do you figure that?
你怎么认为？
Well, you know it's true. Your white candidate who'd been in jail for failing to file a tax return, who wasn't married, rumored to be a homosexual-- everybody knew Harold wasn't Harold homosexual, but that was the rumor they tried to create-- and a disbarred lawyer? No way in the world, if he was white, would he be elected.
嗯，你知道那是真的。你的那位白人候选人，因为没提交报税单坐过牢，没结婚，传闻是同性恋——每个人都知道哈罗德不是同性恋，但那是他们试图制造的谣言——还是个被吊销执照的律师？绝不可能，如果他是白人，他会被选上吗？
What should we think of that?
我们应该怎么想？
What do I think of it? I think here again, well, if South Africa can elect a man who's a felon--
我怎么想？我觉得在这里，嗯，如果南非能选出一个重罪犯——
Nelson Mandela.
纳尔逊·曼德拉（Nelson Mandela）。
Nelson Mandela, for 27 years.
纳尔逊·曼德拉，27年。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Yeah. You know what's interesting about it is none of those criticisms also go to what the white fear was. I wonder, as far as you could tell, what was at the heart of the white fear?
是的。你知道这有什么有趣的吗？这些批评都没有触及白人的恐惧到底是什么。我好奇，就你所能了解到的，白人恐惧的核心是什么？
Because he's Black.
因为他是黑人。
And so the two Chicagos headed to primary day-- white Chicago mostly ignoring the Washington candidacy, Black Chicago abuzz about it. And when he won, the two Chicagos had wildly different reactions, as you might expect. Monroe Anderson was a reporter at The Chicago Tribune at the time. He was one of the few Blacks who worked in the newsroom the day after Harold Washington's primary victory.
于是两个芝加哥走向了初选日——白人芝加哥大部分无视华盛顿的候选人资格，黑人芝加哥对此议论纷纷。而当他获胜时，两个芝加哥有着正如你所预料的那样截然不同的反应。门罗·安德森当时是《芝加哥论坛报》的记者。他是哈罗德·华盛顿初选获胜后的第二天，在新闻编辑室工作的少数黑人之一。
I mean, there was such a somber feeling around that place. I mean, it was like somebody's family member, beloved family member had died or something. I mean, it was just really somber. And we were in this jubilant mood, except you did not feel comfortable expressing it, looking it.
我的意思是，那个地方有一种忧郁的气氛。我的意思是，就像某个人的家人，心爱的家人去世了一样。我的意思是，真的太忧郁了。而我们心情是欢欣鼓舞的，只是你看着的时候感觉表达出来并不舒服。
So we walked around, (SINGING) doo, doo, doo, doo, doo, doo-doo. And then we would go into somebody's office or someplace inside and go, yes! [LAUGHS] And jump up and down and then come out, walk around. Oh, yes. We're reporters, too. Yes, we understand. [LAUGHS]
所以我们四处走动，（哼唱）嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟嘟。然后我们会走进某人的办公室或里面的某个地方，喊道，耶！[笑声] 然后上下跳动，再出来，走来走去。哦，是的。我们也是记者。是的，我们理解。[笑声]
After primary day, things got ugly. Usually, winning the Democratic primary for mayor in Chicago means you've won the office. The Republican Party doesn't count in city elections. But in this case, as Chicago moved toward the general election in April 1983, 90% of white Chicago deserted the Democratic Party to vote for a Republican named Bernie Epton. One of his campaign slogans? "Epton, before it's too late."
初选日之后，事情变得丑陋起来。通常，在芝加哥赢得民主党市长初选意味着你已经赢得了这个职位。共和党人在城市选举中并不占优势。但在这种情况下，随着芝加哥走向1983年4月的大选，90%的白人芝加哥人抛弃了民主党，去投票给一位名叫伯尼·埃普顿（Bernie Epton）的共和党人。他的一条竞选口号是？“埃普顿，趁还来得及”。
Black Chicago saw the Democratic defections as racism, pure and simple. Meanwhile, white policemen circulated hate literature illustrated with chicken bones and watermelons. And in perhaps the most famous incident in the campaign, while stumping with Walter Mondale, Harold Washington had stopped at St. Pascal's church, on the city's white northwest side.
黑人芝加哥人认为民主党人的背叛纯粹就是种族主义。与此同时，白人警察散发印有鸡骨头和西瓜图案的仇恨传单。在竞选期间最著名的事件中，哈罗德·华盛顿在与沃尔特·蒙代尔（Walter Mondale）一起竞选时，在城市白人西北部的圣帕斯卡（St. Pascal）教堂停了下来。
There was almost a riot.
几乎发生了一场骚乱。
Monroe Anderson covered it for the Tribune. There's a racial slur in this next quote that we're leaving in, so you get the full picture here.
门罗·安德森为《论坛报》做了报道。下一段引语中有一个种族歧视用语，我们保留它，这样你就能得到完整的图景。
When Harold showed up and the press entourage showed up, I mean, there was this angry-- I mean, people were, like, approaching the car. I mean, it was just-- people were out of control. I mean, they were-- I thought that we were in physical danger. And then we get to the church, and somebody spraypainted on the church graffiti that said, "Die, nigger, die."
当哈罗德出现，媒体随行人员出现时，我的意思是，有一种愤怒——我的意思是，人们就像是，正在接近汽车。我的意思是，这简直是——人们失去了控制。我的意思是，他们是——我以为我们处于身体危险之中。然后我们到了教堂，有人在教堂上喷涂了涂鸦，写着“去死吧，黑鬼，去死”。
On a Catholic church?
在天主教堂上？
Yes.
是的。
Meanwhile, something curious happened. Occasionally, Harold Washington or one of his supporters would say in passing something like, it's our turn now. And when they did, it made headlines. White Chicago and the mainstream press saw it as more than just ethnic pride. It was seen as threatening. This is one of the ways that being a Black politician in America is different than being a Polish politician or an Irish politician. Judge Pincham.
与此同时，发生了一件奇怪的事情。偶尔，哈罗德·华盛顿或他的支持者会顺口说出类似“现在轮到我们了”的话。当他们这么说时，这上了头条新闻。白人芝加哥人和主流媒体将其视为不仅仅是族群自豪感。它被视为一种威胁。这是黑人政治家在美国不同于波兰裔政治家或爱尔兰裔政治家的原因之一。平查姆法官。
The difference is very, very simple. And that is when the Polish attempt to get a Polish mayor, it's good ethnic politics. When the Irish try to get an Irish mayor, it's good ethnic politics. But when the Blacks try to get a Black mayor, it's racism.
区别非常、非常简单。那就是当波兰人试图争取一位波兰裔市长时，那是良好的族群政治。当爱尔兰人试图争取一位爱尔兰裔市长时，那是良好的族群政治。但当黑人试图争取一位黑人市长时，那就是种族主义。
Glenn Leonard grew up in the white southwest side of Chicago, didn't vote for Harold Washington.
格伦·伦纳德（Glenn Leonard）在芝加哥白人西南部长大，没有投票给哈罗德·华盛顿。
I think a lot of people thought that he was going to bring in a lot of people that were going to be Black and were going to change the city. Now we have our chance. Now let's go ahead and do it.
我认为很多人认为他会带进很多人，那些人将是黑人，并将改变这个城市。现在我们有机会了。现在让我们继续做吧。
Let's right all these so-called wrongs. Whether they were right or wrong, it's another story. Let's right these wrongs. Let's move in. Let's take over. Let's have more of a say in the local government. And people just saw that as a threat. They thought, well, these people are going to come in, move into the corner house or whatever, and another white flight starts again. I think that that was a big fear.
让我们纠正所有这些所谓的错误。不管它们是对是错，那是另一回事。让我们纠正这些错误。让我们搬进去。让我们接管。让我们在地方政府中有更多发言权。人们只是将其视为一种威胁。他们想，好吧，这些人要进来了，搬进拐角的房子什么的，另一次白人外逃又要开始了。我认为那是一个很大的恐惧。
Chicago will become another Detroit, people said, another Cleveland. Property values would fall, businesses leave. Many whites had already fled one set of neighborhoods during white flight. And Glenn says that white Chicago was used to having the late Mayor Daley protect the neighborhoods, for instance, by blocking federal schemes to bring in low-income public housing all over the city. But Harold Washington wouldn't do that.
芝加哥将成为另一个底特律，人们说，另一个克利夫兰。房产价值会下降，企业会离开。许多白人在“白人外逃”期间已经逃离了一批社区。格伦说，白人芝加哥习惯于让已故市长戴利保护这些社区，例如，阻止联邦政府将低收入公共住房带入整个城市的计划。但哈罗德·华盛顿不会那样做。
He was going to obviously no longer block these. And these low-income housing units would come into every neighborhood in the city or whatever. And that would start the ball rolling in your-- what do they call it down there in the Far East, when the communists-- the domino effect, thank you. [LAUGHS]
他显然不会再阻止这些了。这些低收入住房单元将进入城市中的每个社区什么的。那将开始滚动你的——远东那里怎么说来着，当共产主义者——多米诺骨牌效应，谢谢。[笑声]
This is one thing that Black politicians have to deal with that white politicians don't. And this is true from Chicago to Washington, DC, from North Carolina to South Africa. They have to deal with white fear. Harold Washington.
这是黑人政治家必须处理而白人政治家不必处理的一件事。从芝加哥到华盛顿特区，从北卡罗来纳到南非，这都是事实。他们必须处理白人的恐惧。哈罗德·华盛顿。
We have 670,000 Black registered voters in this city. When you get right down to it, the votes are here. They're here. They're here. And every group-- and I've said it before, and I'll say it again. And the press takes it and runs out in left field with it.
我们在这个城市有67万名注册的黑人选民。当你归根结底时，票就在这里。它们在这里。它们在这里。而每一个群体——我以前说过，我还会再说一遍。媒体对此大做文章，跑到左翼去。
Every group that gets our percentage of the population, they don't go around begging. They don't go around explaining. They don't have any excuses to make. They just move on in and take one of their own and put them in office. That's what we should do. That's what democracy is all about.
每一个达到我们人口比例的群体，他们不会四处乞讨。他们不会四处解释。他们没有任何借口可做。他们只是搬进去，带上自己人，让他们担任公职。那就是我们应该做的。这就是民主的全部含义。
The problem is when your opponents don't see your election as just the normal workings of democracy. How Harold Washington tried to rise above their fear after he squeaked out a narrow victory in the general election and took office, it's in a minute, when our program continues.
问题在于，当你的对手不把你的选举视为民主的正常运作时。哈罗德·华盛顿如何在他大选中惊险获胜并上任后试图超越他们的恐惧，一分钟后，我们的节目继续。
This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. If you're just tuning in today, what we're doing is that in this moment, when a Democratic socialist, a Muslim candidate, Zohran Mamdani, stands poised to become the next mayor of New York, sending the Democratic Party into a kind of identity crisis as he does it, we're rerunning this show that we first broadcast back in 1997 about another big city mayor who forced the Democrats to re-examine what the party was all about and pick sides, Harold Washington, Chicago's first Black mayor, who took the mayor's office in 1983 and died just four years later, just a few months into his second term. We rejoin that old episode now.
《这就是美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。如果你今天刚调入，我们正在做的是，在此时此刻，当民主社会主义者、穆斯林候选人佐兰·曼达尼（Zohran Mamdani）即将成为下一任纽约市长，并在此过程中使民主党陷入某种身份危机时，我们正在重播我们在1997年首次播出的节目，关于另一位大城市市长，他迫使民主党重新审视该党的本质并选择立场，他就是哈罗德·华盛顿，芝加哥第一位黑人市长，他在1983年接管了市长办公室，并在仅仅四年后去世，即他第二个任期仅几个月后。我们现在回到那期旧节目。
So in Chicago and most American big cities, the way it used to work-- and I say "used to" with some reservations. You could argue that a version of this still exists lots of places. But the way it used to work was that when Irish-Americans took the mayor's office or Italian-Americans or Polish-Americans, they channeled contracts and patronage jobs and other municipal goodies to their own communities.
所以，在芝加哥和大多数美国大城市，事情运作的方式——我用“过去”这个词保留一点余地。你可以辩称，这仍然存在于许多地方。但过去运作的方式是，当爱尔兰裔美国人接管市长办公室，或者意大利裔或波兰裔美国人接管时，他们会将合同、政客任命职位和其他市政福利输送到他们自己的社区。
Lu Palmer was one of the people at the center of the movement to elect a Black mayor in Chicago. He convened the early organizational meetings in his basement. It is hard to imagine that Harold Washington would have ever come to office without him. And he was disappointed by Harold.
卢·帕尔默是芝加哥选举黑人市长运动核心人物之一。他在地下室召开了早期的组织会议。很难想象没有他哈罗德·华盛顿会当选。而他因哈罗德而感到失望。
I don't know, but he never became what I would consider the Black mayor. Black people wanted something that was so simple-- fairness. And I used to get upset with Harold after he became elected because Harold was too fair. In fact, he would say in his speeches, I'm going to be fair. I'm going to be more than fair.
我不知道，但他从来没有成为我所认为的“黑人市长”。黑人们想要的东西很简单——公平。我过去常在哈罗德当选后对他感到生气，因为哈罗德太公平了。事实上，他在演讲中会说，我要公平。我要比公平更公平。
No one, but no one in this city, no matter where they live or how they live, is free from the fairness of our administration. We'll find you and be fair to you wherever you are.
在这个城市里，没有人，绝对没有人，无论他们住在哪里或如何生活，都能免受我们行政公平的惠及。无论你在哪里，我们都会找到你并对你公平。
And I used to cringe--
我过去常感到畏缩——
But I need your help.
但我需要你们的帮助。
--when he would say, I'm not only going to be fair, but I'm going to be fairer than fair. Well, come on. You know, you don't have to go overboard. And Harold did.
——当他说，我不仅要公平，而且我要比公平更公平。嗯，得了吧。你知道，你不需要做得过火。而哈罗德做到了。
Those of us who are considered radicals, we simply believe that since Daleys, the Daleys, Byrne and all the rest of the white mayors had always put white people first, without any question, without any apology. We said that Harold got to put Black people first. And that's what we wanted.
我们这些被认为是激进派的人，我们只是认为，既然戴利们、伯恩和所有其他白人市长总是毫无疑问地、毫无道歉地把白人放在第一位。我们说哈罗德必须把黑人放在第一位。那就是我们想要的。
I'm not sure we wanted to be to white people what Daley was to Black people. That is, he was just ridiculous. But people wanted to see the opportunity to have our community thrive like other communities.
我不确定我们是否想成为对白人来说就像戴利对黑人那样的人。也就是说，他真是荒谬。但人们想要看到机会，让我们的社区像其他社区一样繁荣。
It wasn't just Black nationalists like Lu Palmer who felt this way. Old-time machine loyalists like Eugene Sawyer, who was the Black alderman that the white Democratic machine wanted to succeed Harold Washington as mayor, said the same thing.
不仅仅是像卢·帕尔默这样的黑人民族主义者有这种感觉。像尤金·索耶（Eugene Sawyer）这样的老派机器效忠者，那个白人民主党机器想要其接替哈罗德·华盛顿担任市长的黑人议员，也说了同样的话。
And that was part of the thing, that I think we probably were too fair. I think Harold was too fair.
而那是其中的一部分，我认为我们可能太公平了。我认为哈罗德太公平了。
In what way?
在什么方面？
A lot of people think he was too fair by giving a lot more and giving everybody the same thing. And people didn't expect it. A lot of Black folks think that he should have given your own people a little bit more.
很多人认为他通过给予更多、给予每个人同样的东西而显得太公平了。人们并不期待那样。许多黑人认为他应该给自己人多一点照顾。
Well, a major problem with being a Black person in America--
嗯，在美国作为一个黑人的一个主要问题——
Reporter Monroe Anderson.
记者门罗·安德森。
--is you're in this trap. Because I mean-- and this is sort of our curse and our blessing because of this racial history, is that we have been complaining and pointing out all these inequities for a very long time. And therefore, all these things that you have pointed out that have been an injustice to you, now that you're in power, you can't do because it'll be injustice to whites. And therefore, the rules have to be this great even, everything's fair and square.
——是你陷在这个陷阱里。因为我的意思是——这算是一种诅咒也是一种祝福，因为这种种族历史，是我们一直在抱怨并指出所有这些不平等已经很长时间了。因此，所有这些你指出对你是不公正的事情，现在你掌权了，你却不能做，因为这对白人来说就是不公正。因此，规则必须是这种伟大的平等，一切公平公正。
People close to Harold Washington say that it was smart politics for him to be fairer than fair. After all, Black wards had been treated so unfairly in the past that simply giving them the same services that the rest of the city got would be a huge step forward. There's also the political stance he felt most comfortable with by disposition.
哈罗德·华盛顿身边的人说，他比公平更公平是一种聪明的政治。毕竟，黑人选区过去一直受到极其不公平的对待，仅仅给他们提供城市其他地方得到的同样服务就已经是巨大的一步了。还有他天性中最习惯的政治姿态。
And when Black politicians or community activists came to City Hall trying to get more for one neighborhood over another, he was so enormously popular in Black Chicago, where 85% of the Black electorate turned out to vote for him, and where everyone simply referred to him as Harold, that he could ignore the pressure. Jacky Grimshaw was a staff person.
当黑人政治家或社区活动家来到市政厅试图为某个社区争取更多利益时，他在黑人芝加哥非常受欢迎，那里85%的黑人选民投了他的票，每个人都简单地称他为哈罗德，他可以忽视这种压力。杰基·格里姆肖（Jacky Grimshaw）是一名工作人员。
I think there is a difference between the Black population and the Black politicians. I think on the part of the Black politicians, it was definitely "it's our turn." And I had to deal with some of these folks. I mean, they'd come in, and they'd want 10 jobs and crap like that. Hey, [CHUCKLES] there ain't 10 jobs. But I think on the part of the people, I mean, they were into fairness. I mean, I think the fairness thing played with them, you know? I mean, they were proud of Harold. They supported him, what he was doing.
我认为黑人人口和黑人政治家之间是有区别的。我认为对黑人政治家而言，那绝对是“轮到我们了”。我不得不与这些人中的一些人打交道。我的意思是，他们会进来，他们会想要10个工作什么的。嘿，[轻笑] 没有10个工作。但我认为对民众而言，我的意思是，他们关注的是公平。我的意思是，我认为公平那件事对他们起作用了，你知道吗？我的意思是，他们为哈罗德感到骄傲。他们支持他，支持他所做的事情。
Privately, Harold Washington talked about the danger of doing away with the old patronage system, how it could make the first Black mayor weaker than any of his white predecessors. But publicly, for all intents and purposes, patronage was over.
私下里，哈罗德·华盛顿谈到了废除旧效忠体制的危险，这可能使第一位黑人市长比他任何白人前任都更虚弱。但公开地，实际上，效忠体制结束了。
It's gone? It's gone. And in the words of Cornell Davis, they said he wasn't dead. So I went to his grave, and I walked around that grave. And I stomped on that grave. And I jumped up and down. And I called out, patronage, patronage, are you alive? And patronage didn't answer. It is dead, dead, dead.
它消失了？消失了。引用康奈尔·戴维斯（Cornell Davis）的话，他们说他没死。所以我去了他的坟墓，我围着那个坟墓走。我在那坟墓上跺脚。我上下跳动。我大声喊，效忠体制，效忠体制，你还活着吗？而效忠体制没有回答。它死了，死了，死了。
[LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE]
[笑声，掌声]
Washington attacked the machine. The machine struck back. From the first day of Washington's first city council meeting, 29 aldermen, all of them white, the old Democratic machine, teamed up to oppose him. For the first time in memory, a Chicago mayor did not control City Hall. For the first time in memory, clout-- that's what we call it in Chicago-- clout, sheer bullying force that was at the heart of Chicago politics, clout was no longer in the mayor's control.
华盛顿攻击了这个机器。机器进行了回击。从华盛顿第一次市议会会议的第一天起，29名议员，全都是白人，旧民主党机器，联手反对他。这是记忆中第一次，芝加哥市长无法控制市政厅。这是记忆中第一次，影响力——这就是我们在芝加哥所说的——影响力，这种芝加哥政治核心的纯粹欺凌力量，影响力不再受市长控制。
It was the machine's 29 votes to Harold's 21 votes. The 29 not only blocked his appointments, it never brought them up for consideration. It blocked most of his legislative initiatives and dedicated enormous energy to looking for ways to embarrass him and thwart him.
那是机器的29票对哈罗德的21票。那29人不仅阻止了他的任命，甚至从不把它们拿出来考虑。它阻止了他大部分的立法倡议，并投入巨大的精力寻找羞辱他、挫败他的方法。
It was mayhem, a battle so divisive and chaotic that it sustained the animosity and suspicion between Black Chicago and white Chicago for years. It came to be known locally as "Council Wars," after a local African-American comic named Aaron Freeman began staging moments in local politics as scenes from the Star Wars trilogy. Harold appeared as Luke Skytalker, leader of the rebellion, constantly spouting off long, difficult words. Harold's main political opponent, Ed Vrdolyak, the alderman who led the 29, also got a big part.
那是混乱，一场如此分裂和混乱的战斗，多年来一直维持着黑人芝加哥和白人芝加哥之间的敌意和怀疑。它在当地被称为“议会战争”（Council Wars），是在一位名叫亚伦·弗里曼（Aaron Freeman）的当地非裔美国喜剧演员开始在当地政治中表演星战三部曲场景后得名的。哈罗德以卢克·天行者（Luke Skytalker）的身份出现，作为反抗军的领袖，不断喷出冗长、生僻的词汇。哈罗德的主要政治对手埃德·弗多利亚克（Ed Vrdolyak），即领导那29人的议员，也得到了一个重要角色。
What are you doing in my office, Lord Darth Vrdolyak?
你在我的办公室里干什么，达斯·弗多利亚克勋爵（Lord Darth Vrdolyak）？
[AMPLIFIED BREATHING]
[放大的呼吸声]
[APPLAUSE, CHEERING]
[掌声，欢呼声]
I wish to discuss committee assignments for the new council. [AMPLIFIED BREATHING]
我希望讨论新议会的委员会分配。[放大的呼吸声]
[APPLAUSE, CHEERING]
[掌声，欢呼声]
I don't have to talk to you. I'm the mayor. I can do whatever I want. I can-- [GASPING, SCREAMING]
我不必和你谈。我是市长。我可以做任何我想做的事。我可以——[喘息，尖叫]
[AMPLIFIED BREATHING]
[放大的呼吸声]
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
I find your lack of respect disturbing. It is obvious you do not know the power of the clout. It has served all of the mayors before you. It can bring you great wealth and power, or it can destroy you as easily. The choice is yours.
我觉得你缺乏尊重，这很令人不安。很明显你不知道影响力的力量。它服务过你之前所有的市长。它可以带给你巨大的财富和权力，或者它可以像毁掉你一样轻易地毁掉你。选择权在于你。
[IMITATING HORN]
[模仿喇叭声]
You do not consternate me, Vrdolyak. Take this parliamentary maneuver! [IMITATES LASER MISSILE]
你吓不倒我，弗多利亚克。吃下这一招议会战术！[模仿激光导弹]
Well done, Mayor. But I counter with this-- negotiated majority. [IMITATES LASER MISSILE]
干得好，市长。但我用这个来还击——协商多数。[模仿激光导弹]
Then I'll file a suit in court! [IMITATES LASER MISSILE]
那么我会在法庭上提起诉讼！[模仿激光导弹]
But the decision is in my favor. [PUFF]
但决定对我有利。[噗]
[SCREAMS] You may have prevailed at this juncture, Vrdolyak, but I will assiduously pursue your disestablishment.
[尖叫声] 你可能在这一关赢了，弗多利亚克，但我会勤奋地追求你的垮台。
[AMPLIFIED BREATHING]
[放大的呼吸声]
Perhaps, Mayor. But to do so, you must use the dark side of the clout. You must make deals and compromises.
也许吧，市长。但要做到这一点，你必须使用影响力的黑暗面。你必须做交易和妥协。
Never!
绝不！
Yes, Mayor. To defeat me, you must become me. Look at my face, Skytalker, for I am your mentor!
是的，市长。要打败我，你必须成为我。看看我的脸，天行者，因为我是你的导师！
No!
不！
[CHEERING, APPLAUSE]
[欢呼声，掌声]
Even under these adverse conditions, Washington did manage to pass budgets and get some things done. Black wards finally got the same street repair and garbage pickup as all the other wards. Jacky Grimshaw describes one scheme Washington came up with to do some improvements around the city, designed to be, of course, fairer than fair, to give every ward the same benefits. But the 29, of course, opposed it. And Washington needed their approval because to pay for it, he wanted to issue a city bond.
即使在这些不利条件下，华盛顿也设法通过了预算并完成了一些事情。黑人选区最终获得了与所有其他选区一样的街道维修和垃圾收集。杰基·格里姆肖描述了华盛顿提出的一个旨在在该城市周围进行一些改进的计划，当然设计得比公平更公平，给每个选区同样的利益。但那29人当然反对它。而华盛顿需要他们的批准，因为为了支付它，他想发行市政债券。
So every ward was to get, I think it was 10 miles of street resurfacing and alleys, a certain number of alleys done, and street lighting. And so he had all of these on the bond issue, and they were refusing to pass it. So he put all of the reporters on the bus, and he would go around to these various wards.
所以每个选区都应该得到，我想是10英里的街道重铺和小巷，一定数量的小巷完成，以及街道照明。所以他把所有这些都列入了债券问题，而他们拒绝通过它。所以他把所有记者都装上公共汽车，他会去这些不同的选区。
And we went out to Mount Greenwood, another area of the city that did not welcome Blacks at the time, to say, your alderman is refusing to support this bond issue that I want to use to give you real streets. And if you want it, you better tell your alderman to vote for it. And so by the time he got through doing this, the folks in the communities were pretty much outraged. Black mayor or not, they wanted their streets. They wanted their sewers. They wanted their vaulted sidewalks repaired and so forth.
我们去了芒特格林伍德（Mount Greenwood），这是城市中当时不欢迎黑人的另一个地区，说，你们的议员拒绝支持我想用来给你们真正街道的债券问题。如果你想要它，你最好告诉你们的议员投票支持它。所以当他做完这些后，社区里的人们几乎都被激怒了。不管是不是黑人市长，他们想要他们的街道。他们想要下水道。他们想要他们的拱形人行道被修复等等。
What happens to American politics when one of the politicians happens to be Black? In this case, what happened was that everything in city politics was seen through the prism of race, even though often it had nothing to do with race. Often, it had more to do with reform. Gary Rivlin is the author of a very evenhanded history of Washington's years, Fire on the Prairie.
当其中一位政治家恰好是黑人时，美国政治会发生什么？在这种情况下，发生的事情是城市政治中的一切都通过种族的棱镜来看待，尽管通常它与种族无关。通常，它与改革有更多关系。加里·里夫林（Gary Rivlin）是华盛顿执政岁月的非常客观的历史书《草原上的火》（Fire on the Prairie）的作者。
You know, everyone wants to understand Harold Washington as the first Black mayor. And it's true, he was the first Black mayor, and that was a very significant thing. But he was also the mayor who beat the Chicago political machine. He was the first reformer in 30 years to take on the machine. And he did it more successfully than anyone else before him, purely on a reform point of view. And so he was a different kind of politician, but no one could ever see beyond his race.
你知道，每个人都想把哈罗德·华盛顿理解为第一位黑人市长。没错，他是第一位黑人市长，那是一件非常重要的事情。但他也是击败芝加哥政治机器的市长。他是30年来第一位挑战该机器的改革者。而且他比他之前任何人都更成功地做到了，完全是从改革的角度出发。所以他是一个不同类型的政治家，但没有人能超越他的种族看到本质。
In fact, there was a political cartoon at the time I loved. And it was an editor asking a reporter covering the election, so anything change? Anything new? And the reporter answered, no, he's still white, and he's still Black. And really, it was never-- [LAUGHS] it really wasn't that much more sophisticated than that cartoon indicated.
事实上，当时我喜欢一幅政治漫画。那是一个编辑问一位报道选举的记者，有什么改变吗？有什么新鲜事吗？记者回答说，没有，他还是白人，他还是黑人。真的，从来就没有——[笑声] 它真的没有比那幅漫画显示的复杂多少。
You pick up a local paper, and these guys just wax so eloquently. They don't know what they're talking about. Don't have the slightest idea about the phenomena. Don't understand the history. Don't understand the mindset. Don't understand what push people. All they say is, gee, Black folks must be angry.
你拿起一份当地报纸，这些人只是文采斐然地胡说八道。他们根本不知道自己在谈论什么。根本不知道这种现象。不懂历史。不懂心态。不懂什么推动了人们。他们所说的只是，天哪，黑人一定很生气。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Gee, Black folks voted for Black folks. They must hate white folks. That ain't got nothing to do with nothing! Nothing! Crazy stuff. But that's what you read around here in Chicago. That's what I had to put up with every day when I look in the reporters' eyes. All that silly business, you know? How many white folks did you convert today, Harold? [LAUGHS] Wow!
天哪，黑人投了黑人的票。他们一定讨厌白人。那跟什么都没有关系！什么都没有！疯狂的事情。但那正是你在芝加哥读到的。那正是我每天看着记者眼睛时必须忍受的东西。所有那些愚蠢的事，你知道吗？你今天转换了多少白人，哈罗德？[笑声] 哇！
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Wow! And the answer is, more than you did, boy. Because I do my job, irregardless of race, color, creed, or sex.
哇！答案是，比你多，小子。因为我做好我的工作，不论种族、肤色、信仰或性别。
Because everything he did, even things that were more about reform than about race, was seen through the lens of race. It gave Washington's opponents a tool that they could use against him, which they did. A typical example-- some crime rates went up between 1985 and '86, even though, overall, crime was lower under Washington than under his white predecessor. But his opponents tried to make the case that this proved the Black mayor did not care about crime. Hate literature had said that he would do nothing about crime because most crime is caused by Blacks.
因为他所做的一切，即使是那些更多关于改革而不是种族的事情，都是通过种族的视角来看待的。这给了华盛顿的对手一个可以用来对付他的工具，他们也确实这么做了。一个典型的例子——一些犯罪率在1985年到1986年间上升了，尽管总体而言，华盛顿执政期间的犯罪率低于他的白人前任。但他的对手试图辩称，这证明黑人市长不关心犯罪。仇恨传单说他会对犯罪不做任何事情，因为大多数犯罪是由黑人引起的。
So they were using this statistical bump between '85 and '86 to prove what the hate literature was saying, that the Black mayor is going to be indifferent to crime. See, that's playing the race card and playing it in a dirty way. It's a way of distorting statistics to play to racial fears out there.
所以他们利用'85年到'86年之间的统计波动来证明仇恨传单所说的话，即黑人市长将对犯罪漠不关心。你看，那是打种族牌，而且是用肮脏的方式打。这是一种扭曲统计数据以利用外界种族恐惧的方式。
So did Washington talk about race? Did he talk about the Chicago political machine always being biased against the Black community? Sure. Is that playing the race card? Sure, but I also happen to think it's true, what he was saying, whereas what I think the opposition was doing much more of was playing the race card and playing it in a dirty way, trying to tweak and abuse statistics any way they could to prove their point and play into the worst fears of the white community. I never saw Washington playing into the worst fears of the Black community. In fact, his rhetoric was, I'm going to be fairer than fair.
那么华盛顿谈论种族了吗？他谈论芝加哥政治机器总是对黑人社区有偏见吗？当然。那是在打种族牌吗？当然，但我恰好也认为，他所说的是真的，而我认为反对派所做的事情更多是在打种族牌，而且是用肮脏的方式打，试图以他们能做的任何方式调整和滥用统计数据来证明他们的观点，并利用白人社区最糟糕的恐惧。我从未看到华盛顿利用黑人社区最糟糕的恐惧。事实上，他的修辞是，我要比公平更公平。
The fact is, by the time he died, just a few months into his second term of office, Harold Washington had put together a working majority on the council. Not many more whites voted for him in his second election than in his first. But every political observer in Chicago says that he was making headway. Patrick O'Connor was one of the 29 aldermen who opposed Washington, who was one of the few swing votes who sometimes sided with the mayor.
事实是，到他去世时，也就是他第二个任期仅几个月后，哈罗德·华盛顿已经在议会中建立了一个工作多数派。在他第二次选举中，投他票的白人并不比第一次多多少。但芝加哥的每一位政治观察家都说，他正在取得进展。帕特里克·奥康纳（Patrick O'Connor）是反对华盛顿的那29名议员之一，他是少数几个有时站在市长一边的摇摆票之一。
We invited him up to a picnic in our ward. And he showed up at our picnic. And he got a great reception. People that really didn't vote for him, and probably wouldn't vote for him the next time, respected the fact that he came out there, that he wanted to say hello, that he wanted to participate. And bear in mind that I was voting consistently with a bloc that was voting against him. And he came out, and we spent the day, and it was fine.
我们邀请他去我们选区的一个野餐会。他出现在我们的野餐会上。他受到了热烈的欢迎。那些真正没有投票给他，而且下一次可能也不会投票给他的人，尊重这样一个事实：他出来了，他想打个招呼，他想参与其中。请记住，我一直在投票支持一个反对他的集团。他出来了，我们度过了那天，这很好。
I remember one time we were both invited to a place that neither of us were particularly popular in the ward. And so I got a call from his office-- and this is, again, at a time when there was a council war going on-- asking was I going to this festival or whatever it was. And if I was, would I meet the mayor on a corner in our ward and go in there together with him? And I told the guy, no, I'm not meeting him on the corner. I said, if he wants me to go, he's got to pick me up at my house.
我记得有一次我们都被邀请去一个在选区里我们都不怎么受欢迎的地方。所以我接到了他办公室的电话——这又是在议会战争正在发生的时候——问我是否要去参加那个节日什么的。如果我去了，我是否会在我们选区的一个街角见市长，然后和他一起去。我告诉那个人，不，我不去街角见他。我说，如果他想让我去，他必须到我家来接我。
So the mayor pulls up to the front of my house. He comes in. We have-- a glass of wine, he had, and I had a beer. We sat around for a couple of minutes, and he met my family. And he looks in my dining room. We didn't have any dining room furniture at the time. The kids were all young, and we'd just moved into the house. So he says, where's your dining room furniture? My wife says, you don't pay him enough money. And Harold goes, I knew this cheese was going to cost me something. I mean, and he was just that quick. He was really very, very good.
所以市长把车开到我家门口。他进来了。我们喝了——他喝了杯葡萄酒，我喝了杯啤酒。我们坐了几分钟，他见到了我的家人。他往我的餐厅看了看。我们当时没有任何餐厅家具。孩子们都很小，我们刚搬进那栋房子。所以他说，你的餐厅家具在哪里？我妻子说，你给他的钱不够多。而哈罗德说，我知道这奶酪肯定要花我一点钱。我的意思是，他就是那么快。他真的非常好。
But my point is, is that we got in the car, we went to this festival, and by the time he left, he had people dancing with him. He went over. He was talking with folks. By the time he left, it might not have changed the mind of everybody in there that he was OK, but he had made a significant impact. And he understood, by keeping that schedule and going through areas where he was not expected to show up or would traditionally not be the most welcome person, that he was winning percentages of people. And that's all he had to do.
但我的重点是，我们上了车，我们去了那个节日，当他离开时，他已经让人们和他一起跳舞了。他走过去。他在和人们交谈。当他离开时，可能并没有改变那里所有人对他OK的想法，但他已经产生了重大影响。他理解，通过保持那个时间表，并穿过那些他不被期待出现或传统上不是最受欢迎的人的区域，他正在赢得一部分人。而他只需要做这些。
Vernon Jarrett says that if Washington had lived, he would have done a lot to ease the strains of modern Chicago apartheid.
弗农·贾雷特说，如果华盛顿活着，他将为缓解现代芝加哥种族隔离的紧张局势做很多事情。
Harold was going to win over a big chunk of the white population. And I don't mean Gold Coast liberals. They were beginning to like this guy. And they could see something in him that represented them. He was chubby, warm, friendly. And not only that, he was going into some lower class white neighborhoods, having the streets paved for the first time. And they were slowly beginning to lose their fear.
哈罗德将赢得很大一部分白人人口。我不是指黄金海岸的自由派。他们开始喜欢这个家伙了。他们能在他的身上看到代表他们的东西。他胖乎乎的，温暖，友好。不仅如此，他还要进入一些低收入的白人社区，第一次把街道铺平。他们正慢慢开始失去恐惧。
Act Two, The Present and the Future. Today's rerun, first broadcast in 1997, 10 years after Harold Washington's death, continues.
第二幕，现在和未来。今天的内容重播，1997年首次播出，即哈罗德·华盛顿去世10年后。
There are ways, I think, that the mayor has changed the city forever, but they are not things you can necessarily measure by doing head counts and using a lot of numbers.
我认为，市长永远改变这个城市的方式有很多，但它们不是你通过进行人数统计和使用大量数字必然能衡量的东西。
Laura Washington, Harold's former press secretary, now editor at a sort of muckraking publication called The Chicago Reporter.
劳拉·华盛顿，哈罗德的前新闻秘书，现在是一家名为《芝加哥记者报》（The Chicago Reporter）的揭黑出版物的编辑。
I think he opened up the city in ways that it will never be closed again. If you look at the numbers, you'll still see a lot of inequity. You'll still see neighborhoods that are poorer, probably poorer than they were 15, 20 years ago. You'll see neighborhoods that still probably don't get their fair share of city services. But you'll see, I think, a dramatic difference in the attitude that public officials and policymakers have to equity in the city.
我认为他以这种方式打开了这座城市，它将永远不会再被关闭。如果你看数字，你仍然会看到很多不平等。你仍然会看到比15、20年前可能更贫穷的社区。你会看到可能仍然没有得到应有市政服务份额的社区。但我认为，你会看到公职人员和政策制定者在城市公平性方面的态度发生了巨大变化。
10 years after Harold Washington's death, people who follow politics in Chicago say that, if nothing else, current mayor, Richard M. Daley, son of Richard J., has to worry about making Black voters angry. He's been careful to have Black press secretaries and kept a number of appointees from the Black administration before him. He's done nothing so far to infuriate Black Chicago the way his white predecessors regularly did.
哈罗德·华盛顿去世10年后，芝加哥的政治关注者们说，至少，现任市长、理查德·J·戴利的儿子理查德·M·戴利必须担心会让黑人选民生气。他一直小心翼翼地聘请黑人新闻秘书，并保留了前任黑人行政部门的许多任命人员。到目前为止，他还没有像他的白人前任经常做的那样激怒黑芝加哥。
City services are distributed more fairly, even today, though there's been a bit of backsliding here and there. And Richard Daley's latest proposed bond issue follows the model of the Washington years. It gives all of Chicago's wards equal benefits, something that was unheard of in the years before Washington.
城市服务分配得更公平，即使是今天，尽管这里和那里有一点倒退。而理查德·戴利最新的债券提案遵循了华盛顿时代的模式。它给芝加哥所有的选区同样的利益，这在华盛顿之前的年份是闻所未闻的。
OK, so this is Ira in 2025 again. Hi. At the end of Harold Washington's first term, 88% of white voters still voted against him. And 10 years after his death, when we first broadcast the program that you're listening to right now, we sent a reporter, Rachel Howard, to the 39th Ward, out near O'Hare Airport, a mostly white ward that voted against Washington, to see if times had changed, to see if they would consider voting for a Black mayor. Short answer, no. Longer answer, she talked to people in a bar who got totally riled up as soon as she mentioned Harold Washington, called him the N-word.
好的，所以这是2025年的艾拉再次上线。嗨。在哈罗德·华盛顿第一个任期结束时，88%的白人选民仍然投票反对他。而在他去世10年后，当我们首次播放你们现在正在听的这期节目时，我们派了一名记者瑞秋·霍华德（Rachel Howard）到第39区，靠近奥黑尔机场，这是一个投票反对华盛顿的主要是白人的选区，看看时代是否变了，看看他们是否会考虑投票给一位黑人市长。简单答案，不。较长答案，她和酒吧里的人交谈，他们一提到哈罗德·华盛顿就变得完全被激怒了，称他为那个N字开头的词。
They would start ranting about how he should have stayed on the South Side, how he wasn't their mayor. 10 years is not a very long time.
他们会开始咆哮他应该留在南区，他不是他们的市长。10年并不是很长的时间。
No, I didn't vote for Harold at all.
不，我根本没投哈罗德。
Why not?
为什么不？
Because he was Black.
因为他是黑人。
Most people I spoke with felt this way. Some even said they were scared when Harold was elected. And at another bar up the street, a guy explained what everyone had been afraid of.
我交谈过的大多数人都有这种感觉。有些人甚至说，当哈罗德当选时，他们很害怕。而在街上另一家酒吧，一个人解释了大家都害怕什么。
We thought, that's it, we're done. And that was a big thing. I mean, North Side's going to be a South Side now. So the North Side and South Side are very segregated.
我们想，完了，我们完了。那是一件大事。我的意思是，北区现在要变成南区了。所以北区和南区非常隔离。
Put it this way. He thought that the Black people were going to take over the city.
这么说吧。他认为黑人要接管这个城市。
No, no, not that. Those slums be slums. You worry about slums.
不，不，不是那个。贫民窟就是贫民窟。你担心的是贫民窟。
OK, so that was 1997. But then we went back, 10 years after that, 2007. And I have to say, it was interesting, the change. Reporter Rob Wildeboar went to a bunch of the wards where Harold Washington was not welcome back in the day-- the 10th, the 11th, the 23rd wards. And he talked to 50 people, and all but three of them said they would be willing to vote for a Black mayor. Now, to be clear, people were openly racist, OK? Unapologetic about it, like this guy, Pete.
好的，那是1997年。但后来我们回去了，10年后，2007年。我不得不说，这很有趣，变化。记者罗布·威尔德博尔（Rob Wildeboar）去了许多哈罗德·华盛顿当时不受欢迎的选区——第10、第11、第23区。他采访了50个人，除3个人外，所有人都说他们愿意投票给一位黑人市长。现在，明确一点，人们公开表现出种族主义，OK？对此毫不掩饰，就像这个家伙皮特（Pete）。
We bought a house here in Hegewisch. And what happened? Blacks moved in. Taking over the parks, taking over the schools, taking over everything. Go on a holiday to Wolf Lake. Well, who's over there? They're all barbecuing over there. We can't even go to our own parks. We got nothing.
我们在赫格维什（Hegewisch）买了房子。结果发生了什么？黑人搬进来了。接管公园，接管学校，接管一切。去狼湖（Wolf Lake）度假。嗯，谁在那里？他们都在那里烧烤。我们甚至不能去我们自己的公园。我们什么都没有。
But then the same guy said that he wished that a Black alderwoman, Toni Preckwinkle, would run for mayor. He'd vote for her, he said. She did a great job cleaning up Hyde Park. Or there was a woman named Mary Kay, who lived in the 23rd Ward by Midway Airport, the neighborhood where Washington got the lowest vote total in the city in 1983, less than 1%, just 199 votes. Mary Kay was not one of the 199. And she told our reporter, Rob, things are just different now.
但后来同一个人说，他希望黑人女议员托尼·普雷克温克尔（Toni Preckwinkle）竞选市长。他说他会投票给她。她说她在海德公园（Hyde Park）做了出色的清理工作。或者有一个叫玛丽·凯（Mary Kay）的女人，住在中途机场（Midway Airport）旁的第23区，华盛顿1983年在该社区获得了该市最低的得票率，不到1%，只有199票。玛丽·凯不是那199人之一。她告诉我们的记者罗布，时代真的变了。
Back then, for me, it was white or Black. [LAUGHS] You know? I was prejudiced back then, probably, more so than I am now.
当时，对我来说，是白人还是黑人。[笑声] 你知道吗？我当时有偏见，可能比现在多得多。
There's still some lingering around?
还有一些残留吗？
Oh, yeah. [LAUGHS] A little bit, you know? Don't turn my back on them, but yeah. [LAUGHS] No, I mean, that was 20 years ago. I don't have that fear these days. Now I accept you, Black or white, you know? And Washington didn't do bad. I mean, he was a decent mayor.
哦，是的。[笑声] 一点点，你知道吗？不要背对他们，但是是的。[笑声] 不，我的意思是，那是20年前了。这些日子我没有那种恐惧。现在我接受你，不管是黑人还是白人，你知道吗？而华盛顿做得并不坏。我的意思是，他是一位正派的市长。
So what's changed?
那么什么变了？
Everything. I mean, I've changed. They've changed, you know. The Black people are more educated. They're standing on something these days. They've come a long way in this world. And they deserve-- they worked hard. I mean, you see it in the stores, you know? They're doing just as good as that. They're well dressed. They're clean. They're not the ghetto. And they want what we got, what we've always had.
一切。我的意思是，我变了。他们也变了，你知道吗。黑人受教育程度更高了。他们这些日子是有立足之地的。在这个世界上他们走得很远。他们应得的——他们努力工作。我的意思是，你在商店里看到了，你知道吗？他们做得和那个一样好。他们穿得体面。他们干净。他们不是贫民窟。他们想要我们得到的，我们一直拥有的。
Every group-- and if the press is listening, I want them to hear this. They didn't hear it when I ran for office. I'll say it again. Every group, when it gets population ascendancy, as night follows day, decide, without malice to anybody, not anger to anybody, that it is their turn! Period. That's all.
每一个群体——如果媒体在听，我希望他们听见这个。我竞选公职时他们没听到。我再说一遍。每一个群体，当它获得人口优势时，就像夜尽天明一样，决定，不对任何人有恶意，不对任何人有愤怒，这就是轮到他们了！句号。就是这样。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Ain't nothing wrong with that! And I made that statement two months ago, and they said it was racist. But they left out most of the statement, which the Irish do it, the Polish do it, the Jews do it, and every intelligent group on Earth, which is every group, does it. And we do it. And we should do it. And we do it in a positive sense, not in a negative sense.
那一点错都没有！我两个月前发表了那个声明，他们说那是种族主义。但他们遗漏了大部分陈述，即爱尔兰人这样做，波兰人这样做，犹太人这样做，地球上每一个聪明的群体，也就是每一个群体，都会这样做。我们这样做。我们应该这样做。我们以积极的意义这样做，而不是以消极的意义。
You're not anti-Irish because you're pro-Black. You're not anti-Black because you're pro-Jewish. I mean, that doesn't follow. You just happen to be pro. And as long as you're not-- as long as you are not anti, as long as you are not anti, your pro-ism is acceptable. So it's just that simple. Now, I hope the press gets it right this once.
你不是因为亲黑人就反爱尔兰。你不是因为亲犹太就反黑人。我的意思是，那不成立。你只是恰好亲某方。只要你不是——只要你不是反，只要你不是反，你的亲某主义就是可以接受的。所以就这么简单。现在，我希望媒体这次能把它搞对。
[CHEERING, APPLAUSE]
[欢呼声，掌声]
So obviously, that's Harold. And then before that was tape from 2007, voters speaking 20 years after he died. 2007, that same year, you may remember, there was another Black Chicagoan in politics capturing people's attention. Barack Obama was running for president.
显然，那是哈罗德。在那之前是2007年的录音，选民在去世20年后发表讲话。2007年，同一年，你们可能记得，政治上有另一位黑人芝加哥人吸引了人们的注意。巴拉克·奥巴马（Barack Obama）正在竞选总统。
Some of you may know that I originally moved to Chicago in part because of the inspiration of Mayor Washington's campaign. And for those of you who recall that era and recall Chicago at that time, it's hard to forget the sense of possibility that he sparked in people.
你们有些人可能知道，我最初搬到芝加哥部分是因为哈罗德·华盛顿市长的竞选激励。对于那些记得那个时代并记得当时芝加哥的人来说，很难忘记他激发起人们的可能性感。
When Barack Obama ran for Senate, and later, for president, one of his advisors was David Axelrod, a man who was uniquely positioned to comment on how racial politics have changed in Chicago since Harold's time, because he was also a political advisor to Harold Washington, back during Harold's second run for mayor.
当巴拉克·奥巴马竞选参议员，后来竞选总统时，他的顾问之一是戴维·阿克塞尔罗德（David Axelrod），这个人处于独特的地位来评论自哈罗德时代以来芝加哥种族政治发生了怎样的变化，因为他也是哈罗德·华盛顿在第二次竞选市长时的政治顾问。
Back in 2007, I reached Axelrod on his cell phone to talk about that. It was during the Obama campaign. He was on a campaign bus in Iowa. He told me back then that things had significantly changed in Chicago's white wards in the years since Harold's death.
早在2007年，我在他的手机上联系了阿克塞尔罗德谈论那个话题。那是在奥巴马竞选期间。他在爱荷华州的一辆竞选巴士上。他当时告诉我，自哈罗德去世以来，芝加哥白人选区的情况发生了巨大变化。
I remember that the night of the 2004 Democratic primary for the US Senate, when Barack Obama was nominated. And one of the things that I looked at that night was how he did on the northwest side of Chicago. When Harold ran, he got 8% of the white vote in his first primary. I think he got 20% in the re-election. And much of the determined resistance was on the northwest side of Chicago.
我记得2004年美国参议院民主党初选的那天晚上，当巴拉克·奥巴马获得提名时。那天晚上我关注的事情之一是他在芝加哥西北部的表现。哈罗德第一次参加初选时，他获得了8%的白人选票。我想他在连任时获得了20%。而坚定的抵制大部分是在芝加哥的西北部。
And Obama carried all but one ward on the northwest side of Chicago. He even carried the precinct in which St. Pascal's church sits. That was the church where Harold Washington and Walter Mondale campaigned in 1983 and met with really hostile resistance from the crowd. Obama carried that precinct. And I said to Barack that night, I think Harold's smiling down on us tonight.
奥巴马赢得了芝加哥西北部除一个选区外的所有选区。他甚至赢得了圣帕斯卡教堂所在的选区。那就是哈罗德·华盛顿和沃尔特·蒙代尔在1983年竞选并遇到人群真正敌意抵制的那个教堂。奥巴马赢得了那个选区。那天晚上我对巴拉克说，我想哈罗德今晚在看着我们笑。
When Obama got to the general election for senator, he won 70% of the vote or more in every white ward in the city. His results weren't far from that when he ran for president. And years later, when Kamala Harris ran against Donald Trump in 2024, that mostly held. Most of those white wards went solidly for Harris, with 60% or 70% voting for her. Trump only won one Chicago ward out of 50.
当奥巴马进行参议员大选时，他在城市里每一个白人选区都赢得了70%或更多的选票。当他竞选总统时，他的结果也差不多。而多年后，当卡马拉·哈里斯（Kamala Harris）在2024年与唐纳德·特朗普（Donald Trump）竞选时，大部分保持了这种状态。大多数那些白人选区坚定地支持哈里斯，60%或70%的人投票给她。特朗普在芝加哥50个选区中只赢得了一个。
When I asked the people who urged Harold Washington to run in the first place-- that's Lu Palmer and Timuel Black-- what the lessons of the Washington years are, they both said the same thing. They talked about how it was a mistake to think you could make the world change if you pinned your hopes on just one man. After Harold died, the movement died, too.
当我问那些首先敦促哈罗德·华盛顿参选的人——即卢·帕尔默和蒂缪尔·布莱克——华盛顿时代的教训是什么时，他们两人说了同样的话。他们谈到了如果你把希望寄托在一个人身上，你就认为能改变世界，那是一个错误。哈罗德去世后，运动也死了。
And I'll tell you, a lot of people don't like to criticize Harold Washington-- I blame Harold for this.
我会告诉你，很多人不喜欢批评哈罗德·华盛顿——我为此责怪哈罗德。
What should have been happening, we should have anticipated either his demise or removal from office, and been organizing for that possibility.
本来应该发生的是，我们应该预见到他会去世或被免职，并为这种可能性做好组织工作。
Harold was put on a pedestal. And I think that was a major mistake. We lifted him to almost God status.
哈罗德被放在了基座上。我认为那是一个严重的错误。我们将他提升到了几乎上帝的地位。
Barack Obama noticed the same problem. In fact, there's a passage in Dreams From My Father about this, when he writes about what Chicago was like immediately after Harold's death.
巴拉克·奥巴马注意到了同样的问题。事实上，在《来自我父亲的梦想》（Dreams From My Father）中有一段关于这个的描述，当他写到哈罗德去世后芝加哥的样子时。
The day before Thanksgiving, Harold Washington died.
感恩节前一天，哈罗德·华盛顿去世了。
This is Obama, reading on the audiobook.
这是奥巴马，在有声读物上朗读。
It occurred without warning, sudden, simple, final, almost ridiculous in its ordinariness, the heart of an overweight man giving way. It rained that weekend, cold and steady. Indoors and outside, people cried. By the time of the funeral, Washington loyalists had worked through the initial shock. They began to meet, regroup, trying to decide on a strategy for maintaining control, trying to select Harold's rightful heir.
它发生得毫无预警，突然、简单、最终、平凡得近乎荒谬，一个超重男人的心脏放弃了工作。那个周末下着雨，冷而持续。室内和室外，人们在哭泣。葬礼时，华盛顿的拥护者们已经度过了最初的震惊。他们开始会面、重组，试图决定维持控制的策略，试图挑选哈罗德合法的继承人。
But it was too late for that. There was no political organization in place, no clearly defined principles to follow. The entire of Black politics had centered on one man, who radiated like the sun. Now that he was gone, no one could agree on what that presence had meant.
但那太迟了。没有任何政治组织到位，没有明确定义的原则可以遵循。整个黑人政治都集中在一个人身上，他像太阳一样辐射。现在他走了，没人能就那种存在意味着什么达成一致。
I guess it's worth pointing out that this is what so many Democrats said when Barack Obama left office, and Donald Trump came to power, that Obama and his team didn't leave the Democratic Party in proper shape to face the battles ahead.
我想指出，这就是许多民主党人在巴拉克·奥巴马离任、唐纳德·特朗普上台时所说的，奥巴马和他的团队没有让民主党处于适当的形状来面对未来的战斗。
In 2017, after Donald Trump was elected for the first time, I checked again with David Axelrod. He told me that Harold might have been surprised that a Black man was elected president just two decades after Harold won his second term. But he said Harold would not have been surprised at the backlash, once that Black man got to the Oval Office.
2017年，唐纳德·特朗普第一次当选后，我再次咨询了戴维·阿克塞尔罗德。他告诉我，哈罗德可能会惊讶，在哈罗德赢得第二个任期仅仅二十年后，一个黑人就当选了总统。但他表示，一旦那个黑人进入椭圆形办公室，哈罗德对反弹不会感到惊讶。
Well, today's program was originally produced back in 1997 by Alex Blumberg and myself, with Nancy Updike, Alix Spiegel, and Julie Snyder. Senior editor for the show was Paul Tough. Production help from Rachel Howard, Seth Lind, Bruce Wallace, BA Parker, Matt Tierney, Suzanne Gaber, Stowe Nelson, and Michael Comite.
好吧，今天的节目最初是由亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）和我自己在1997年制作的，还有南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）和朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。该节目的高级编辑是保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough）。制作帮助来自瑞秋·霍华德、塞思·林德（Seth Lind）、布鲁斯·华莱士（Bruce Wallace）、BA帕克（BA Parker）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）、苏珊·加伯（Suzanne Gaber）、斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）和迈克尔·科米特（Michael Comite）。
Since we first put the show on the air nearly 30 years ago, four of our interviewees, Lu Palmer, Vernon Jarrett, Eugene Sawyer, and Judge Eugene Pincham, have died. None of them lived to see a Black man win the Oval Office, or, of course, what's happened since.
自从我们近30年前第一次播出这档节目以来，我们的四位受访者卢·帕尔默、弗农·贾雷特、尤金·索耶和尤金·平查姆法官已经去世。他们中没有一个人活着看到黑人赢得椭圆形办公室，或者当然，没有看到之后发生的事情。
We used archival footage today from the following sources, from Brian Boyer's film, Harold Washington and the Council Wars, from Bill Cameron's taped recordings of Harold Washington's speeches and press conferences. We got tape from Chicago's Museum of Broadcast Communications, thanks to Bruce DuMont and the staff there.
我们今天使用了来自以下来源的档案镜头，来自布莱恩·博耶（Brian Boyer）的电影《哈罗德·华盛顿与议会战争》，来自比尔·卡梅伦（Bill Cameron）的哈罗德·华盛顿演讲和新闻发布会的录音带。我们从芝加哥广播通信博物馆获得了录音带，感谢布鲁斯·杜蒙特（Bruce DuMont）和那里的工作人员。
Also from Howard Gladstone and Jim Ylisela's film, The Race for Mayor; from Bill Stamets's film, Chicago Politics-- A Theater of Power; and from WBBM's archival news footage. WXYT Radio gave us archival tape of Aaron Freeman's Council Wars satire. And WTTW-TV gave us archival footage of the '83 debates.
还有来自霍华德·格拉德斯通（Howard Gladstone）和吉姆·伊利塞拉（Jim Ylisela）的电影《市长竞选》；来自比尔·斯泰梅茨（Bill Stamets）的电影《芝加哥政治——权力的剧场》；以及来自WBBM的档案新闻镜头。WXYT电台给了我们亚伦·弗里曼的《议会战争》讽刺节目的档案录音带。WTTW电视台给了我们'83年辩论的档案镜头。
In addition to all that, we'd like to thank Eva Baeza, who at the time was director of the Chernin Center for the Arts at the Duncan YMCA. And thanks to Gary Rivlin, who gave us advice throughout this production. We recommend his book, Fire on the Prairie. It's a great history of the Washington years. Thanks to Hugo Tyrel and Dolores Woods.
除了所有这些，我们要感谢伊娃·巴埃萨（Eva Baeza），她当时是邓肯基督教青年会（Duncan YMCA）切尔宁艺术中心（Chernin Center for the Arts）的主任。感谢加里·里夫林，他在整个制作过程中给了我们建议。我们推荐他的书《草原上的火》。这是华盛顿岁月的伟大历史。感谢雨果·泰雷尔（Hugo Tyrel）和多洛雷斯·伍兹（Dolores Woods）。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to the co-founder of our program, Mr. Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《这就是美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交流中心）分发给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
(SINGING) Bet your bottom dollar you lose the blues in Chicago, Chicago
（哼唱）拿上你的最后一点钱，在芝加哥失去忧郁，芝加哥
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Let us close out today with a recording from the night of Harold Washington's second mayoral victory.
让我们以哈罗德·华盛顿第二次市长胜利之夜的录音来结束今天。
(SINGING) On State Street, that great street
（哼唱）在州街，那条伟大的街道
I just want to say
我只想说
They do things they don't do on Broadway, hey
他们做着百老汇不做的事情，嘿
They have the time, the time of their life
他们拥有时光，他们一生中最美好的时光
I saw a man, he danced with his wife
我看到一个男人，他与他的妻子跳舞
In Chicago, Chicago my hometown
在芝加哥，芝加哥，我的家乡